>>Female Presenter: Today it is my pleasure
to introduce our speaker to you.
Born right here in the Bay Area, Michael Ellsberg
is a renowned expert in entrepreneurialism,
career development, and education, whose work
has been featured in the New York Times, the
Wall Street Journal, CNN, and Good Morning
America to name just a few.
Michael is author of the incredibly popular
"The Power of Eye Contact: Your Secret for
Success in Business, Love, and Life," a book
that provides simple tools for improving relationships
throughout all areas of your life.
He also writes the Need to Know blog for Forbes
dot com, which is full of even more valuable
tips for personal success.
His new book, "The Education of Millionaires:
It's Not What You Think and It's Not Too Late,"
will be released on September 29th, but we
were lucky to get a few pre-release copies
over here if you're interested.
While the workplace today often places heavy
importance on a person's alma mater, for his
new book, Michael spent the past year and
a half interviewing some of the world’s
most successful individuals who did not obtain
a college degree.
Instead, these individuals were self-taught
and learned the skills they needed for success
through their experiences in the real world.
In his talk today, Get Rich and Invest In
Your Own Human Capital, Michael will explain
how to make the most fast-acting, direct,
high-impact investments in your own human
capital and career success based on what he
learned from these masters of self-education
and from his own personal experience.
And with that, please join me in welcoming
Michael Ellsberg.
[applause]
>>Michael Ellsberg: So, what I plan to do
in the next 45 minutes is to radically alter
the way you all think about the concept of
investing.
Now, you are all highly accomplished engineers,
managers, executives, professionals in Silicon
Valley, the heart of innovation in America.
You all work for a legendary company in the
history of capitalism.
So, for me to stand up here and say that in
45 minutes I might alter the way you think
about a concept as fundamental as investing
is a tall order, but that is what I'm gonna
aim for today.
So, I'm not here to talk about stocks, bonds,
real estate, 401Ks.
You've all heard those kinds of lectures before.
You all know the rap about that kind of investing.
The type of investing I wanna talk about is
one you've probably heard less about 'cause
it's discussed a lot less.
But I think it's very, very important.
And that is investing in your own human capital.
And the title of the talk today is "Get Rich
Investing In Your Own Human Capital."
If you haven't guessed already, its slightly
tongue in cheek title, I wanted to poke a
bit of fun at all those books about the other
kind of investing.
Get rich investing in real estate!
But in all seriousness, I do think that investing
in your human capital can potentially much
more lucrative than all those other kinds
of more traditional investments.
It's possibly much more safe, which is something
that we're all interested in now given the
craziness of the markets in the last several
years.
And it also can be possibly more rewarding
and more fitting in with the fabric of your
career and your sense of meaning.
So, that's what we're gonna be talking about.
And I'm gonna start with a pretty uncontroversial
statement.
We'll get to a bit on controversy later.
But let's start with uncontroversy.
Most economists, most career development professionals,
will agree that spending your time, spending
your money, investing in human capital is
a really good investment.
So, you're not gonna find many people who
disagree with that statement.
But almost all the discussion around that
concept focuses on investments in formal credentials
and formal higher education.
And those can be very powerful investments.
And I know that Google, as a corporate culture,
highly values educational attainment, educational
investments in its employees and its recruits.
And you've all probably in this room made
a lot of those investments.
And those can be very powerful, very worthwhile
investments.
But almost all the discussion centers around
those.
And there's a whole world of investments that
I've been exploring over the last several
years talking to very successful people who
didn't go that path, who boot-strapped their
human development, their human capital.
And so, if you think of formal education,
it might be thought of as almost a venture
capital model of investing in your human capital
in that there's often a lot of financing involved,
a lot of effort in money up-front; sixteen,
eighteen years to get through elementary school,
undergraduate, more years for graduate education.
And then, after all this investment, all this
potentially financing in debt, then you get
some benefit afterwards.
And what I want to talk to you about today
is styles investing in yourself that can just
be put into action right now with not a lot
of expenditure of money.
You don't have to leave this wonderful campus
where there's all this free food available
that I've already been enjoying.
And you don't have to take time off from your
career.
You don't have to go into student debt.
It's available to you right now.
So, these might be thought of as more of a
boot-strapping model of human capital development.
Or, lean.
Lean is a very hot word now in the investing,
entrepreneurial world.
Or, you could think of it as a guerilla-style
of investing.
So, that's what we're gonna be talking about
for the next 40 minutes or so.
Now, before I dive in, who am I?
Why the heck do I have any credibility at
all to be talking with you about this today?
So, I'm a professional author, book author.
This is my second book that's been published.
There's a few before that weren't published.
I won't talk about those.
But this one is coming out in a couple weeks
from Penguin.
It's called "The Education of Millionaires."
And you're actually some of the first people
to hear about it or even see it.
I just saw this book like two days ago for
the first time.
And what I did is I got very interested in
this question of how can you develop your
talents outside of the normal ways that we
hear about developing your talents, going
back to school.
And to explore that question, I decided to
interview some of the most successful people
on the planet who don't have college degrees.
And I went around the country.
I talked to about 35 millionaires, self-made
millionaires, entrepreneurs, who didn't finish
college, about four billionaires.
Some of them are pretty famous.
Dustin Moskovitz, co-founder of Facebook.
I talked to Sean Parker, founding president,
who by the way, if you've seen the movie "The
Social Network," I think he is totally different
than Justin Timberlake.
They did him a disservice in that movie after
hanging out with him for a couple hours and
picking his brain about this stuff.
I interviewed Matt Mullenweg, who is the founder
of Wordpress.
I run my own personal blog on that.
Probably a lot of you are familiar with Wordpress.
Outside of the tech world, I spoke John Paul
DeJoria.
He's the co-founder of John Paul Mitchell
Systems.
He was homeless at two points in his life
early.
Lived out of a car with his son and was at
one point collecting soda bottles to make
sure that he had enough money to feed his
son.
And he went in business with a hairdresser
called Paul Mitchell.
They invested, I think, like 700 dollars in
creating their first formula.
They went salon to salon, built it into a
multi-billion dollar business.
And he's been on the Forbes 400 forever now.
And another person on that list I interviewed
was Phillip Ruffin, who started out building
a hamburger ch--.
Not even a chain, a stand.
A hamburger stand in college.
He eventually decided to drop out to build
that.
Built it up quite successfully.
Just kept building businesses.
Now he owns Treasure Island Resort and Casino
on Las Vegas strip.
So, a bunch of famous people.
I also just interviewed people you probably
haven't heard of, but who are just doing really,
really interesting cutting edge things.
The inspiration for my book actually was my
wife, Jenna, who's here in the front with
my mother.
And Jenna is a successful entrepreneur.
She has a thriving weight loss coaching practice
and wellness center in Manhattan.
And she dropped out of college in Australia.
So, she was the inspiration for me getting
excited about this topic.
For the record, I did graduate--Brown class
of '99.
So, I'm not an example of the people that
I write about.
[pause]
So, we're gonna get into some really specific
takeaways that I wanna give you in this next
40-odd minutes.
You're gonna come away with some really specific
things you can implement for your career success.
Before we dive into that, I wanna get a kind
of more Google Earth view of the issue and
then we'll zoom in more specifically towards
the end of the talk.
And we'll also have plenty of time for questions.
So, the Google Earth view.
In my write-up for this talk, which you may
have seen or not, I'm not sure, I start out
with a comparison about two different types
of people.
Take a billionaire executive.
You probably know of a few here in this company,
or just someone who is at the top of their
game in the corporate world.
And then you take someone who's earning minimum
wage, which is around seven fifty an hour
these days.
These two people don't have very much in common
professionally.
They pretty much couldn't be more opposite
Except, they have one really, really important
thing in common.
Can anyone guess what that one thing they
have in common is?
They both have 24 hours in the day.
I don't care how much money you have.
There are ways you can use money to leverage
your time.
But I don't care how much money you have,
even if you owned all the stock of Google
on IPO day and cash it out that day, all that
money could not buy you a 25th hour of the
day.
So, we're all working with 24 hours.
So then the interesting question becomes,
what distinguishes these two kinds of workers
who have the same amount of time to work with?
Why is one earning so much more than the other?
And it's quite dramatic.
The average executive compensation for CEO
of a major corporation is around ten million
dollars in both salary and stock options and
benefits.
I know that Larry and Sergey were at one point
taking one dollar, so they're not the best
example here.
But your average CEO of a large corporation
is around ten million dollars.
They don't get paid hourly, but if you break
that down say, 80 hour weeks, 50 weeks a year,
you're looking at somewhere around three thousand
dollars an hour the market is valuating their
time versus someone whose minimum wage pouring
coffee kinda thing is getting valued at seven
fifty.
And they're both putting in roughly the same
amount of time each day.
So, what is the difference between them?
Well, economists, when they look at who's
earning what and why people are earning more,
they have this concept called "productivity,"
the productivity of someone's work.
And productivity is a pretty simple function.
It's just a function of labor, the time you're
putting in, mixed with capital.
So, you take the same amount of labor.
You mix it with more capital.
And you get more productivity, more compensation.
So you think of someone who's earning minimum
wage, their capital is a mop and very basic
level of training to clean what they're cleaning.
It's a low amount of capital.
They're mixing their time and they get low
results financial-wise, whereas very highly
compensated executive is putting in roughly
the same hours, but they are mixing those
hours with an enormous amount of capital for
each minute they're putting in.
It's being mixed with an enormous amount of
capital.
They have, of course, a human capital.
They have their training, formal education,
and their informal training, all their experience
on the job.
They have a rolodex, which is a form of human
capital, or it might be called social capital.
Then they have all the capital of the company.
They have executive teams that can put their
vision, execute on their vision.
They have all the financial resources accompanied.
So each minute is being mixed with a lot of
capital and that's why more value gets created
out of each minute.
So, what I wanna do today--.
You all have a lot of human capital already
in your expertise, your education, of course
your experience, but I wanna give some really
guerilla-style boot-strapped ways you can
start adding even more to your human capital
so that each minute of your time, each hour
you spend here is mixed with more capital
and therefore, more valuable.
And that your career will develop that much
faster, your compensation, your earnings will
develop that much faster.
So, I'm gonna talk about four main types of
lean, or boot-strapped, human capital that
we can all add to.
And the first one I'm gonna talk about is
sales.
And that might sound a little bit crazy.
I'll bet a lot of you in the audience are
engineers.
You may not ever in your career get in a position
of formally selling something in the context
of the business.
Maybe some of you do, but my guess is probably
most of you don't.
So, why would I be standing up here telling
you that learning about sales is a valuable
way to add to your human capital?
Well, even if you're not selling a product
for money, all of us, all of you, are working
in a knowledge economy, a knowledge society
here.
And we'd like in a certain sense, you're getting
paid for your creativity and your ideas.
And we'd like to think that the best ideas
win, but we know in office politics, in just
the way things work, that isn't always the
case.
The ideas that win are the best ideas multiplied
by the best persuasion, the best influence,
the best sales, if you will, of those ideas.
So, formal education, which we've all had,
I've had, teaches us about the ideas.
It's a pure idea environment where there's
this very high premium on coming up with brilliant
ideas.
But the thing that you don't tend to learn
in a formal environment is how to pitch and
sell and persuade those ideas to real world
teams in the real world.
And someone I interviewed for this book actually
once went through the entire course catalog
of Harvard's, Stanford, and Wharton Business
Schools and was looking for courses in sales.
And there was not a single course in sales
in the entire MBA catalogs of those three
most prestigious business MBA programs.
There was one course in sales force management,
which is very different from sales.
Now, if you talk to the people I interviewed
in my book, these self-made millionaires,
self-made billionaires, successful entrepreneurs,
if you talk to them about what was behind
their success, they are almost all very, very
passionate about the concept of sales, both
traditional sales in the sense of selling
things for money, but just as much, sales
in a sense of persuasion and a sense of getting
people excited about your ideas.
And you all are very idealistic.
You wanna make a big impact on this company.
You want a big impact in the world of tech,
Silicon Valley.
And what I'm putting forth to you is that
your impact, the leverage point here is actually
gonna be your persuasiveness in pitching your
ideas.
Now one resistance that a lot of people have
and I used to have around the idea of learning
sales or persuasion is that it sounds kinda
manipulative.
The word sales has a bad ring to it.
The word persuasion has a manipulative ring
to it.
And the truth is, there is a lot of really
manipulative, cheesy, low-grade sales out
there.
And that's where we get that impression is
that it exists.
And it has that connotation of an encyclopedia
salesman or a used car salesman.
Well, I'm not here to tell you to learn that
kind of sales.
I promise.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Hopefully, well, Wikipedia is putting encyclopedia
salesmen out of business.
Maybe the Google's Car project will put used
car salesmen out of business.
We don't know.
You can just order your car off the internet.
If you guys did a good job on your algorithms,
you could put insurance salesmen out of business,
auto insurance salesmen, if these cars aren't
crashing into each other.
So, I'm looking forward to that.
No more of that kind of sales.
The kind I'm talking about is high integrity
sales.
And it does exist.
If you're somehow resisting the concept of
learning to be more persuasive because you
think it's cheesy or manipulative, that is
actually, I think, an excuse that is holding
you back from furthering your career.
'Cause there are ways to learn this stuff
that are high integrity, that are befitting
of your careers of the Google brand.
So, a very specific recommendation I wanna
make is a book called "SPIN Selling," S-P-I-N
Selling, by Neil Rackham.
And this is, in my opinion, the best book
on sales ever written.
As far as I know, the only book that is based
on actual observation of in-field sales sessions.
And they were doing--.
They had a budget of a million dollars and
I think dozens and dozens of researchers and
they went all around the country observing
in-field sales sessions of high-ticket priced
items that were considered major sales by
the buyer.
And what they found, fortunately for all of
us, is that that kind of slickster manipulation
doesn't actually work.
That's not what is ultimately what is persuasive
in pitching your ideas to your teams, to people
who are gonna buy your ideas.
And what works is two things: asking the right
questions and listening very closely to the
answers.
And so that, actually, the more the person
you're trying to persuade talks, the more
likely you are to persuade them of your vision.
And so, sales becomes not a cheesy pitch,
but actually a human conversation where you're
listening to your team, you're listening to
what you want, and you're finding ways to
demonstrate that you really get what these
people care about and that tailoring what
your pitching, what you're selling, quote,
unquote, to their needs.
And when people get that feeling that you're
tailoring that way, they listen and they're
persuaded.
And your ideas start diffusing through your
team and through the company.
So, there is one example of a very highly
leveraged way to invest in your human capital.
I just mentioned one book.
I think it's probably 30 bucks at most.
You can read it in a few evenings.
You don't have to leave Google.
You don't have to go into a master graduate
program and take on student debt to start
making these kind of investments in your career.
You can do them in this boot-strapped, on
the fly way.
So, the second type of human capital I wanna
talk about today, the second type of investment
is attention, investing in the quality of
your attention.
Now, this is a huge issue in the tech world,
in all of us who are involved with computers.
We know Facebook, Twitter, now Google+ is
just one more thing to keep us distracted
in the day.
Everyone, email, IM, text message, everyone
is struggling with this.
I don't know anyone who's not struggling with
issues of attention during their workday.
And if you take two people who have roughly
the same educational credentials, roughly
the same training, technical knowledge, same
background, and one of them has a fantastic
attention and just gets to work.
They've got a clear mind.
They're focused.
They can get right to work and not be distracted
and they're going throughout the day with
a great level of energy and focus and attention.
And you compare that to your typical corporate
worker, who is drinking three or four cups
of coffee just to get awake in the morning,
get started, gets distracted by all these
social media things, doesn't really know where
they're going in a workday, maybe has to have
another huge jolt of caffeine in the afternoon
just to get through the day.
You compare those two people and the first
person I mentioned is gonna win in a career
ten times out of ten.
So, that's again another type of investing
in your human capital that is highly leveraged
in that it doesn't take a lot of money.
This is stuff you can learn about.
You can focus on your time and your money
and your attention and you can change yourself.
And we can all change ourselves this way.
And it has a huge impact on our careers.
And if you think again about productivity
is being labor times capital, you all have
a certain amount of labor that you're bringing
to the table here.
Eight, ten, twelve hours a day.
I don't know quite how much all of you are
spending each day, but it's a fixed amount.
So, we're talking about changing things in
ourselves that makes each of those minutes
you bring to the table more productive.
And that ends up in bringing much, much higher
career results.
So, there's a lot of ways to focus on attention.
I just saw a wonderful sign there about meditation.
So, there's techniques you can learn.
I mean, there's a sign right there you can
check out about a meditation group.
There's a specific kind of investing in your
attention span and the quality of your attention
that I wanna talk about that's very near and
dear to my heart.
I had a pretty serious problem with this issue
in my 20s.
I'm 34.
Four years ago, on the eve of my 30th birthday,
I was suicidal.
And I had struggled throughout my 20s with
Bipolar II, which a pretty serious mental
illness that involves really strong mood swings.
So, my attention was really either--.
It was one of two things.
It was either super jacked up, where I was
like this and could barely contain myself,
which was surprisingly actually hard to be
productive 'cause my mind was just so jacked
up.
Or, I was in bed and I could barely get out
of bed and pull the covers off of me.
So, neither of those was very conducive to
good work.
And if you think this stuff about attention
is airy-fairy and New Age, it really isn't.
It has a very direct correlation with your
earnings.
So, in the darkest moments of that period,
I was working as a freelancer and I earned
in my lowest year eight thousand dollars in
one year.
'Cause I just wasn't able to bring quality
attention to my hours in a day.
And it showed in my pocketbook.
And the way I got out of this, it was a long
story.
I actually wrote an article about it on Forbes.
If you Google my name and Bipolar II, I have
a very detailed article about it.
But essentially, I got of this through better
nutritional and eating habits.
And I went through a whole gauntlet of doctors,
psychiatrists.
I was on all kinds of drugs.
And eventually, I came to a doctor who knew
that there were nutritional components to
attention and to mood.
And he told, specifically with these mood
swings, that sugar was a really big issue
and blood sugars issues.
And he told me to get off caffeine, alcohol,
and refined sugar, which I was all of them
consuming in rather high quantities.
I resisted this advice for quite a while.
I basically told him to F-off and that I didn't
wanna live without those things.
Eventually, it got really bad, as I mentioned.
I was literally on the verge of suicide.
I was like, "I need to make a change."
I implemented what this doctor told me.
And within two weeks, my life had radically
transformed.
And so, you don't need to be in the brinks
of that level of darkness to have this effective.
Google is on the forefront, literally the
forefront, and I'm not saying this to flatter
you.
It's actually true, of paying attention to
people, worker's nutrition as a component
of their value in the company and the attention
they're bringing.
And Google has gotten deservedly a ton of
great press about the healthy food that's
available to you in the cafe and all of that.
But we can always do better.
We can always learn more.
There's a very high leverage way to increase
the value of each minute you're bringing to
your day, is to get this part of your life
handled.
To get your nutrition, your health, really
And probably all of us could tick off a list
of the basic things you need to do to be healthy.
We all know it's basically eat more fresh
fruits and vegetables, cut down on refined
sugars, cut down on alcohol consumption and
caffeine consumption, get more exercise, get
better sleep.
All of us know these things.
But really the difference--.
The difference is whether we implement them
or not.
So, again, this is in some ways one of the
fallacies of formal training and education
is that it's really about like what you know
and do you know things intellectually and
can you tick them off on a test.
But what you know is only part of the issue.
Really, it's what you put into practice.
And that is actually in some ways the more
challenging part.
And you really have to train at these things.
I think there's an analogy to training like
an athlete.
You actually have to train your taste buds,
your senses to respond to healthier eating.
And it is a training process.
I have another specific recommendation.
A book that was very helpful to me in this
process of transforming my own life is called
"The UltraMind Solution" by Dr. Mark Hyman.
He's an MD.
It's a very straight-forward, scientifically-based
book on the nutritional aspects of mental
performance and mental health.
A lot of books on alternative nutrition have
woo-woo New Age concepts.
This is a very straight ahead book written
by an MD.
I highly recommend it.
And again, this is the kind of thing maybe
that book is 15, 20 bucks.
You can read it.
You don't have to leave your job to bring
this kind of education into your life.
And that's really what I've been talking about
in this book is that I think institutions
of higher learning have inappropriately monopolized
the word "education."
They all undoubtedly provide very good education
and important and valuable education.
But that's all we think of when we think of
the word "education" is going to school, taking
classes, getting a degree, getting advanced
degrees.
And we don't think about all the other ways
that we can educate ourselves for, oftentimes,
much less expensively and often much more
relevant to what you're doing right now in
your careers.
There's just all these ways available to us
and that's really what I interviewed all these
people about was just the more street smart
ways that they went about educating themselves.
'Cause this group that I talked to is really
probably the group in the world that has the
most success with the least formal credentials
for that success; the most success with the
least formal credentials.
And so, all of their success came in these
more street smart, practical intelligence
type ways.
So, we've talked about sales, persuasion.
We've talked about your attention.
The third one I wanna talk about might ruffle
some feathers, but I think it's really important.
And that is what I call "overcoming emotional
liabilities."
Overcoming emotional liabilities.
And I have a very technical definition of
emotional liabilities.
You might want to take notes on this technical
definition.
I define an emotional liability as any emotional
issue you haven't dealt with that could come
back and bite you in the ass.
And we all have these.
All of us.
I definitely, definitely have these.
All of us in this room have emotional liabilities.
Usually, we're not aware of them.
Another way you might think of them is blind
spots.
So, everyone else is aware of them.
I assure you your team is aware of your emotional
liabilities.
You're the only one who isn't.
Same thing goes for me.
One that I struggle with a lot--.
So, there's several kinds that I'll talk about
that are very common in the work world.
One that I personally struggle with a lot
is defensiveness, which is essentially being
totally unopen to any kind of feedback around
your improvement.
My wife is laughing.
She is the one who is the mirror to my blind
spots.
So, she'll say something very reasonable,
very normal, wifely criticism of a husband.
And I'll get extremely defensive and I'll
deny it and I'll start criticizing her right
back.
And she's very patient.
I'm very lucky to have such a patient wife,
who will patiently and compassionately say,
"Honey, you're doing that defensiveness thing
again."
And she's gotta actually point it out to me
'cause when you're in the grips of it, you're
actually not aware of it.
You're possessed by this and you don't see
it, but everyone else sees it.
So, defensiveness.
Another one that's extremely common in the
work world is what I "victim mentality."
And I have a whole chapter about that in here.
I call it the "entrepreneurial mindset versus
the employee mindset."
And these are mindsets.
This is not about whether you're actually
an entrepreneur or an employee.
It's about mindset.
And one thing that I noticed about all the
people I interviewed is they seem to have
a mindset in common.
And I call that mindset the "entrepreneurial
mindset."
And it's very relevant if you're an employee
also.
The essence of that mindset is a complete
absence of any kind of victim mentality and
a sense that these people are creating the
results around them.
They are the cause of the results.
So, if you're in a victim mentality, everyone
else is the cause of your results, of your
bad results.
So, if your team doesn't do well on a project,
"Well, it's my team members.
They didn't get that piece of programming,
that piece of code in on time."
All those kinds of excuses that we always
hear.
So, you're not really the cause of the bad
things in your life, but the problem with
that is that it throws the baby out with the
bath water.
If you're adopting this mentality where everything
else is the cause, then you're not really
the cause of good things in your life, either.
And so, the people I interviewed have a very
different mindset around this.
And I think it stems from them being entrepreneurs.
Where, if you're an entrepreneur and one of
your employee’s screws up, maybe some entrepreneurs
say, "Oh, well the employee is terrible.
It's their fault.
That's why we messed up."
But those kinds of entrepreneurs don't last
very long.
The ones that are successful say, "OK, this
is my fault.
I created this.
Either I made a bad hiring decision, in which
case I need to fix that.
Or, I didn't provide the leadership necessary
to have that employee do the right thing.
So, I'm in control.
I'm in the driver's seat.
I'm creating my reality."
There's a lot of cheesy stuff out there about
this issue, the law of attraction and "you
create your own reality."
I think for a lot of things that gets overblown
and overhyped.
And you can fairly have skepticism about some
of the more extreme New Age ways that this
gets expressed in like that movie "The Secret."
But just on a basic level, overcoming this
emotional liability of "I'm a victim," "other
people are screwing me over in my career,"
"if just that one employee, if just that one
boss did something different than I'd get
the results I want," that's an emotional liability.
And learning to overcome that is a very, very
powerful way to invest in your own human capital.
So, if you think about the most successful--.
Think about the best leader you can imagine,
either a boss you've had or just an idealization
of your perfect boss/leader.
So, this person is highly inspiring, highly
motivating, makes you wanna work for her,
makes you want to bring out your best to perform
for the vision she's setting out, is giving
you really hard-hitting solid feedback, but
done in a very compassionate way that's not
aimed at cutting you down, but rather in helping
you grow.
So, you think about the most inspiring leader
like that.
And we've all probably had one or two in some
context or another.
That person has overcome a lot of their emotional
liabilities 'cause we've all got them from
childhood.
My mother is here, also.
I had a very happy childhood, but just from
normal growing up stuff, we've all got this
baggage that we carry around and if we don't
learn to let go of the baggage, it will come
back to bite us in the ass.
And it will affect, this is not airy-fairy
New Age stuff.
it will affect your bottom line.
And so, again on the theme of specific takeaways,
on this one, emotional liabilities is very
hard to do just on your own because as we
said, they're blind spots.
So, you need feedback.
And I'm a very big believer in executive coaching.
I'm almost like a religious convert to executive
coaching.
It's transformed my own life, my own earning
power.
I mentioned in the darkest days of my professional
life, I earned eight thousand dollars in one
year.
That was just about four or five years ago
until I finally got my health issues taken
care of, which is the second kind of human
capital we talk about.
And then I was in a place to start, once I
got my health taken care of, to start focusing
on my money.
And I said, "You know what?
I can't be in this place any longer.
I've got to get my money handled.
And I'm not gonna attract--.
No woman that I want to spend my life with
is gonna wanna be married to such a financial
basket case."
And this is before I met Jena and I really
had my vision.
I needed to get this handled to meet the kind
of partner that I wanted to have in my life.
So, I invested and it was literally a financial
investment in really high-quality coaching.
And there's all kinds of workshops out there,
coaching you can get.
Again, there's enormous amount of BS out there.
I would say, I'm probably gonna piss some
people off for listening to this on the video,
but I would say 80% of coaches I've come across
are pretty messed up in their own life and
they're using coaching as a way to sort out
their own life by coaching other people.
That's a really, really common meme that you'll
see out there.
So, you gotta find the people who aren't like
that, who actually have their stuff already
handled.
And who can help you get your emotional liabilities
What's the best way to find them?
Referrals is always the best way I think.
Find people who've got this stuff handled.
Find people who are where you wanna be.
Find, whether in this company or elsewhere
in the Valley, find people who are where you
wanna be and ask who they learned from.
What books did they read?
What teachers did they have?
What mentors did they have?
It's possible that those people teach workshops,
teach classes.
I'll make two recommendations right here if
you're looking for specific recommendations.
I have no--.
I'm not affiliated with these people.
I have no benefit from recommending them,
but one is actually a former Googler, Jenny
Blake, who used to organize this Authors@Google
series.
And she was an executive coach here at Google
and she decided to go out and do it full-time
herself.
She's great.
She's helped me a lot.
She's a friend now.
I actually pay an executive coach also.
So, there's a mix of informal and formal.
So, you can find mentors, which is a form
of coaching.
But I really do believe in investing with
your wallet and paying for some executive
coaching.
I pay for an executive coach.
He's a guy called Peter Shallard.
S-H-A-L-L-A-R-D.
He goes by the moniker, "The Shrink for Entrepreneurs."
And I think we're all, whether employees or
not, we all live in an entrepreneurial environment.
We all need some kind of shrink quote/unquote.
And so, go out and find one that works for
you and make that investment.
A good executive coach--.
The going rate for a really good one who knows
what they're doing is about a thousand dollars
a month.
And that may sound like a lot, but compare
that, for example, to going back and getting
a master’s degree.
That could be 50 thousand dollars a year for
a good program plus forgone earnings.
That could be another 50 to 100 thousand dollars
a year in forgone earnings.
Much of that will be put on debt.
So, there's gonna be interest associated with
the debt.
So, you're looking at possibly 150 thousand
dollars a year to get that kind of formal
increase in your human capital, whereas a
really good executive coach might be one-tenth
of that in a year.
It's gonna be a form of education, but highly
tailored to your specific needs and your specific
circumstances.
And again, this is like a more kind of guerilla
lean style where you don't have to leave your
job.
This is done in dialogue with your job, this
kind of education.
And all the people I talked to in this book
are really, really big believers in the power
of mentorship.
And since they didn't have formal educations,
they didn't have professors, they had to go
and find their professors in the world.
So, I have a chapter, the second chapter in
the book, is a step-by-step way to go on how
to find informal mentors who can help you
with these issues and help us get to that
higher, more clean level of leadership where
we're not getting triggered and weighed down
by emotional baggage issues.
So, that's the third kind of human capital
investment.
And the last type of human capital that I'm
gonna talk about today is meaning and bringing
meaning to our careers.
And I have another pretty serious personal
story around this.
After dealing with that whole bipolar health
issue, I got out of it.
I got out alive.
Pretty soon after that, I got diagnosed with
testicular cancer about two and a half years
ago.
And knock on wood, I got the surgery four
days after I found out about it.
I was on the surgery table.
I got the surgery.
Everything seems to be OK now.
So I am a cancer survivor of two and half
years.
And it's kind of clichéd or cheesy, but there's
something about being diagnosed with a potentially
fatal illness that gives you a permission
slip to really start thinking about these
big issues.
Like, what does my life mean?
What impact do I really want to make here
on the planet?
And so, I thought about those a lot during
the time of the surgery and after.
And I just spent a lot of time thinking about
those issues.
And to me, it's actually kind of sad that
it generally takes a life-threatening illness
for us to give ourselves permission to start
thinking about these issues in our life.
Steve Jobs just stepped down from his incredible
tenure of leadership.
There's a really beautiful commencement speech
he gave in 2005 at Stanford where he talks
about this and he talks about his cancer diagnosis
and how he started thinking about these big
picture issues facing death.
And my hope is that we all in this room don't
have to face those issues for a very long
time and we all live very, very healthy long
lives.
But I want us to give ourselves permission
to think about those issues without facing
mortality and do it now.
And again, this is not an airy-fairy concept.
It has direct relevance to your success in
your career.
So, if you take two people again, same educational
background, same training, same technical
skills.
One of them is just showing up for work like,
"Hey, Google's a cool place to work and get
this free food.
It sounds cool on my resume."
And that's their relation to their work.
Not a lot of meaning.
And you take someone else who has a very clear
sense of what they want to accomplish on this
planet, of what impact they want to have made
in their company, in the industry, in the
world, through their work.
Which one of those two people is gonna be
promoted faster?
Which one is gonna advance in their career?
Which one is gonna earn more over their career?
It's really clear the latter one will.
So, I'm gonna give you my definition of meaning
and how we can add more to it.
I'm sure that you did not expect coming at
12 PM at a lunchtime talk to get a definition
of the meaning of life, but I'm gonna give
you mine right here from a lot of reflection.
The way I like to think about it is the way
we can add more meaning to our lives and our
career is making a difference in the lives
of people you care about.
Making a difference in the people you care
about.
And there's two components to that.
Making a difference and the people you care
about.
And both of those components need to be there
for a sense of meaning.
So, I have two of the most important people
in my life here: my mother, who gave me life.
My wife, who gives me life every day and inspiration.
And these are people I deeply, deeply care
about.
And Jena and I just had our one year wedding
anniversary.
And a year ago, a little over a year ago,
I was giving her my vows in the wedding and
I said, "Jena, I vow to you that if you're
ever in danger, if you're ever in harm's way,
I will sacrifice everything.
I will sacrifice even my own life to protect
you and to get you out of harm."
And I meant those words and there's very few
people on the planet I would say those words
to, but I said them to Jena that day.
And that is a level of meaning that I'm talking
about here.
That's the level of care and we all have that
in our families.
We all have that with people we love, whether
it's a spouse or significant other, children,
siblings, parents.
And so, we get this is in our personal life
that that's what gives us meaning is making
a difference.
On that difference point, it's not just caring.
It's also--.
This is--.
Jena is someone I care deeply about and I
know I'm making a difference in her life.
I know that her life is very different because
I'm in it and we have a relationship.
And it goes both ways.
My life is completely different and pretty
much unrecognizable because of Jena's care
and the difference she's making on me.
So, it's the caring and the making a difference.
So, how does this translate into the professional
realm?
Well, the level of care may or may not be
that intense, but you all work with people.
We like to think--.
We may think that we're here because of technical
skills, because of training background.
But nothing gets done without people.
And you all work on teams.
And presumably, you care about your teams.
And there's an analogy here.
If you interview soldiers about why they fight,
why they put up with these horrendous, hellish
conditions, what keeps them going day after
day on no sleep, risking their life every
day?
If you interview people like that about why
they do it, they may say something about the
cause or the reason they're fighting or their
country.
But if you really dig deep and read the interviews
with them, almost always they're talking about
their team mates, their fellow soldiers and
this profound love and care they have for
the people that on are on their side.
And it's very elemental thing in our psychology,
this caring for teams.
So, the more you learn how to get in touch
with why you're here, why you care about what
you're doing, the people you care about, and
getting really, really inspired by making
a difference in what they're doing, the more
powerful your career is gonna be, the more
powerful each minute of your labor, which
is fixed.
You only have a certain amount of it each
day.
So we're talking about how to make it the
most effective.
The more each minute of that labor is gonna
be powerful.
And there's not really books or things you
can do.
This is inquiry.
This is internal inquiry that we all have
to do.
And it tends to get put aside for other types
of investing.
So, people, when they think of investing,
they think of stocks, bonds, real estate,
portfolios.
A common benchmark is that you're supposed
to put 10% of your pre-tax earnings into retirement
and that kind of savings and investment.
So, that's roughly 10% of your energy going
towards that kind of investment.
But we never ever talk about these, giving
ourself time for these kinds of investments
in our human capital.
And the people I talked to for the last two
years, this is their focus.
I mean, these are masters, masters, of investing
in their own human capital in very inexpensive
ways, without having to go into debt, without
having to take out student loans.
Again, I'm not trying to bash those things.
All of you have probably done a lot of that
in your life.
I'm just trying to expand the conversation
in a direction that it hasn't gone very much.
[pause]
So in closing, I hope that this talk has inspired
you to change the way you view the concept
of investing.
That all of the things that I'm talking about
are actual investments of things that matter
to you.
I mean, even than money, what's more valuable
to all of us than money is time.
And all of these things are gonna take time.
I'm not minimizing the amount of time that
these things are gonna take: to learn to be
a more persuasive communicator about your
ideas, to learn to increase the quality of
your attention through better health habits,
to learn to get over these emotional baggage
issues that we all have, to do this deep inquiry
into what is meaningful for you about your
career, why you show up every day other than
just collecting a paycheck.
Those are all gonna take time.
But in my view, these are extremely powerful,
lucrative ways to invest your time, your energy,
and your money.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
So, we have some time for, let me just see
how much time we have here.
We have some time for about ten minutes for
questions, so any questions from the audience.
Yes.
>>Audience: [inaudible]
>> Michael Ellsberg: Here.
>>MALE #1: So, thank you for the talk.
One of the things, though, when you're talking
about attention, you gave these two examples.
The person who comes in, has to drink a ton
of coffee to wake up and then the person who's
naturally there and they're fully focused.
I mean, those are two rather extreme examples.
I think probably the majority of people here
fall into the middle.
They know they need to focus.
They're trying to focus.
But distractions still come up.
Do you have any thoughts or specific things
that you do or that some of the people in
your book do to actually be able to maintain
that focus for extended periods of time at
work amidst all the distractions?
>>Michael Ellsberg: Right.
Great.
So, the question, if you didn't hear it is
probably all of us in this room are more in
the middle of that range that I gave that
we're not complete basket cases with our attention,
but even if we're in the middle of that road,
how can we improve even further?
So there's the street eye view and the bird's
eye view.
A lot of the books out there on this topic,
a really popular one in the tech world is
"Getting Things Done" by David Allen.
It could be useful for you.
It focuses on really day-to-day strategies
of this kind of stuff.
The issue I have with that book and those
kinds of books is that they tend to be very
good about how you should plan your tasks,
but they don't really get you thinking that
much about which tasks you should be doing
and which ones are gonna have the highest
impact.
And I actually think, again, that that inquiry
into your meaning about, like what you really,
what are the really important things you wanna
be accomplishing here?
That is a big picture inquiry that can cut
out 80% of the low-level tasks that you have
to do if you really get in touch with that
meaning.
On the more street eye view, a system--.
This is an area I'm still working on a lot.
A system that I have found very useful is
called the Pomodoro Technique.
Has anyone heard of that one?
If you look it up, Pomodoro, there's a lot
of stuff of it online.
The name comes from the Pomodoro kitchen timers,
those tomatoes that you twist and it tick-tocks
in the kitchen.
And the idea is that it's basically a timer
and you can get digital versions of this.
That goes for 25 minutes.
And in 25 minutes, you focus on one thing
and you turn off all the email and the notifications
and the Facebook and the Google+ and all these
things.
You focus on one thing for 25 minutes.
The timer goes off.
You get a five minute break and you can do
whatever you want.
You can go and get tea.
You can make some cell phone calls.
You can check your Facebook.
Then the timer goes off in five minutes.
You go back to 25.
That cycle, they call it a Pomodoro.
You do four of those Pomodoros, which is roughly
two hours.
And then you can take a longer break.
And I found that to be really, really effective
in my own life.
I'm self-employed.
I work at home, so I don't have a team that's
keeping me on track.
So, I have needed to implement something like
this to stay on track.
But there's all kinds of things out there
like that available to you really cheaply.
And I guess my big picture point is to not
view those things as extras.
Like, "Well, maybe if I have some time I'll
learn those things."
These are things that are going to make your
labor more valuable next week, the week after
that, day after day, month after month, and
you will see the results in your career and
in your earnings and in the leadership you're
able to take.
[applause]
There's books available over there.